[Music]
back in 2011 journalist and author
michael scott moir agreed to write a
book about the pirates
we've been plaguing the coast of East
Africa he'd hoped to get close to his
subject but not as close as he got soon
after arriving in Somalia in January of
2012 Moore was captured by pirates he
was held prisoner for more than two and
a half years until a ransom secured his
freedom Michael Scott more details his
harrowing journey in the new book in the
desert and the sea 977 days captive on
the Somali pirate coast and he joins us
at the table this morning good morning
I'm gonna ask a question your mother
would ask what were you thinking you
know you wanted to tell the story but
what were you thinking when you went out
there well I went there after covering a
trial for about a year in Hamburg of ten
Somali pirates who were arrested trying
to capture a German ship so I was deep
in the story already and I I went with a
documentary maker who was also
interested in doing something down there
so we planned the trip for a long time
and finally in early 2012 we went down
there oh I'm sorry I can continue no and
spent a couple of weeks researching what
actually led to the spread of piracy in
the region well it started with the
illegal fishing you hear all the time
that pirates are just frustrated
fishermen but it's not quite that simple
the roots of piracy though are in the
fact that the Somalia lost its
government and about 1991 and in the 90s
there was a lot of illegal fishing off
the coast and there were Somali regions
that were trying to defend the coastline
you attempted escape many times what
fueled your once but what would fueled
that well anger no I did I didn't like
being a hostage and I they after about
three months they captured me on land
but after about three months they placed
me on a fishing ship a lot like the
fishing ship on the cover of the book
and it was a tuna vessel that they had
captured not in Somali territorial
waters by the way they went out hundreds
of miles and captured it and we spent
this I spent the summer of 2012 on this
ship and I'm also a surfer
and after a while what's the anchor
chain broke something went very wrong on
the ship I decided to try and escape
you know when you spend that much time
obviously you're being held captive but
what did you learn about them that maybe
you wouldn't have I know that sounds
crazy but that you wouldn't have if you
had not been around them for that amount
of dough well the most surprising part
was was that most of my guards were very
devout Muslims
I didn't think going in that I would
find anyone who was sort of self
deceptive enough to think that they
could be religious and be a pirate at
the same time but that was a
contradiction that took a while for me
to figure out one of the ways you got
through this was actually practicing
yoga yeah in some cases practicing
you'll go with your captain yeah well
once I was hauled off the ship and held
on land in sort of a series of prison
houses there was I actually requested a
mat because at some point I realized I
was going to spend some time and a lot
of time in this one house and the floor
was filthy but I asked for a mat and I
was gonna try and do yoga without the
guards seeing me but they watched me 24
hours a day so I just started to do it
and they thought it was hilarious yeah
and then a few of them started to join
in and after a while they kept because
they were also not getting any exercise
in this house they were locked into so
they kept doing it and I would give them
pointers
what mix of emotions do you have when
you finally set free yeah that's a good
question I by that point I wasn't really
capable of elation you know I wasn't
just immediately happy I I was first of
all I didn't believe I was going free
and then I was sort of I felt more
relaxed and lightened sort of in stages
during the whole day but it wasn't until
I actually saw my family when I was back
in Berlin that that I really felt good
well we're glad you're here me too we're
glad you're safe Michael's got more we
appreciate you talking about this thank
you very much